Grant also didn't know how these ordered
cancellations would affect the total
amount of money he would make. We can't
really help Grant with his business
issues, but we can help him with the math
he needs to know about. So which of these
expressions down here should replace the
question mark right here, to create an
equation for the future earnings that
Grant will have after all of these orders
are paid for? Remember that we need to
take into account, both the money that he
thought he was going to make from all of
the orders he originally received, and
then also, the money that he will no
longer make from the orders that have now
been cancelled. Please assume that money
from all original orders, and money from
cancelled orders down here are positive
when written on their own.